this video was sponsored by kiwiko more
about kiwiko at the end of the show
i know what you're thinking clickbait no
one has measured the speed of light
that's ridiculous the speed of light is
exactly 299 million 792
458 meters per second we are so sure of
it that since 1983 we've actually
used the speed of light to define how
long a meter is
it's just the distance light travels in
a vacuum in one over two nine nine
seven nine two 792 458 of a second that
definition
ensures that the speed of light is
exactly
this number no decimals but
hear me out in this video i will prove
to you that light
may never actually travel at this speed
and i can say that because no one has
actually
measured it we can't measure the speed
of light the same way we measure the
speed
of anything else
i think we're recording everywhere what
are we doing this is a video about
measuring the speed of stuff okay tell
me about how you measured the speed
of the baseball fired out of your cannon
well to get the speed of the baseball
you need to know two things you need to
know the distance
between two points and you need to know
the time that it takes the baseball to
travel between those points
so basically we took distance divided by
time and that's the speed of the
baseball
and in our case we were shooting with a
high speed camera so you basically just
count the frames
and then your clock is internal oh
you're going relativity you're gonna do
something weird aren't you
you saw it coming i can't believe it oh
man the thing i want to ask you about
is the speed of light okay could you
measure the speed of light like this
imagine you have a laser that can fire a
beam through
a perfect vacuum for one kilometer start
a timer
the instant you fire the laser beam then
exactly when it hits the end
stop the clock except how do you know
when light reaches one kilometer
if you and the clock are at the starting
point
okay so you need two clocks one at the
laser and one at the end
which stops automatically when it
detects the laser light
but now how do you make sure your two
clocks are synchronized
well you could connect them via a wire
and send a pulse from one to the other
but that pulse will travel at the speed
of light so
it will arrive with a time delay you
might think
you can just subtract that time delay
but is equal to the time it takes for
light to travel one kilometer
that's what we don't know and are trying
to measure
okay new plan start with the clocks
together
and sync them up first and then send one
of the clocks down to the end
now what could possibly go wrong
well i'll tell you the clock at the
finish line was moving with respect to
the one at the start
and special relativity tells us moving
clocks tick slow relative to stationary
observers
so by the time the clock reaches one
kilometer it will no longer be in sync
with the clock at the start
can i tell you the only solution to this
problem
ditch the second clock put a mirror at
the end to reflect the light back
and use a single clock at the start to
time the full two kilometer round trip
wasn't this actually done before he was
on a mountain and there's a wagon wheel
with a lantern
and there's something like a mirror on
the other side of the mountain i've
always wanted to do this
so uh that sounds a little like how the
speed of light was first
experimentally measured by epolite fizzo
in 1849
he shot a beam of light between the
teeth of a rapidly spinning gear to a
mirror
up on a hill eight kilometers away and
then by
increasing the speed of the gear he
reached a point where the reflected
light passed through the next gap on the
gear
and so it was observed so he measured
the speed of light to be
313 000 kilometers per second
which is within five percent of the
presently accepted value
so someone has measured the speed of
light
or have they what has been measured is
the
round trip or two-way speed of light but
no one has measured the one-way
speed of light one thing i'm going to
throw at you and i'm just going to
i'm just going to come out and tell you
it's like what if the speed of light
in this direction is different from the
speed of light in this direction
then that sounds like a veritasium video
the question is could you figure it out
the kind of crux of this problem
is that the only way people have managed
to measure the speed of light
is for a round trip no one's ever
managed to measure the speed of light in
just one direction
it's possible that the speed of light is
half
of c in one direction and then
instantaneous on the return journey
what that's that's possible are you
serious
think about communicating with an
astronaut stranded on mars
let's call him mark we send out a signal
and get a response 20 minutes later
so we imagine our signal takes 10
minutes to get there
and the reply takes 10 minutes to come
back
but it's possible that our message took
all
20 minutes to get there and the reply
came back
instantaneously there's no way we could
tell the difference between these two
scenarios
but why would the speed of light be
different well
it's possible that there is some
preferred direction through space-time
i mean our universe has a lot of
symmetries but there is also some
asymmetry
for example why is there so much matter
relative to antimatter
and physicists have worked out
internally consistent theories of
physics in which the speed of light
is different forwards and in reverse the
speed of light could vary by just a few
percent
up to at the extreme going c over two in
one direction and
infinitely fast in the other direction
okay so let me let me figure this out so
yeah i
i kind of don't believe you i kind of
don't believe you
i don't believe you that light is a
different speed in one direction but in
the other but i know you well enough to
know that you wouldn't
you wouldn't call me and put a camera
on me unless you knew you were right and
that's what scares me about this
that scares me
[Laughter]
now you might think it is just simpler
that light should travel at the same
speed in all directions
but the truth is that is a convention
rather than an experimentally verified
fact
einstein himself pointed this out in his
famous 1905 paper
on the electrodynamics of moving bodies
he spends the first couple of pages
on the problem of synchronizing clocks
at different locations a
and b and he says there is no way that
we can meaningfully compare the times
they measure
unless we establish by definition that
the time required by light to travel
from a to b
equals the time it requires to travel
from b to a
he's essentially defining that the speed
of light in opposite directions
is the same and he puts by definition in
italics to remind us
that this is only a convention it's
known as the einstein synchronization
convention
so the idea that the speed of light is
the same in opposite directions
as einstein would later write is neither
a supposition nor a hypothesis about the
physical nature of light
but a stipulation that i can make of my
own free will to arrive at a definition
of simultaneity
that sounds a lot more subjective than
how i think most people
would imagine the speed of light is
defined dude
this is hardcore
[Laughter]
i've never thought about this i didn't
think about this before either i always
assumed that when we said
the speed of light is c we meant the
one-way speed of light there's no way to
define the one-way speed of light
so the only thing we can really define
is the two-way speed of light just
look at the way einstein defines c it's
for the round trip from a
to b and back i don't know if you saw in
your physics classes but whenever there
was a light clock
it would always bounce the light up and
then back you would never see a light
clock just bounce slight one way
and this is why the only thing we can be
certain
is constant for all inertial observers
is the two-way speed of light
for over a hundred years scientists have
tried to find a way around this
to measure the one-way speed of light by
itself
here is a paper published in the
american journal of physics in 2009 that
claims to measure the one-way speed of
light
and here is the paper debunking this
study pointing out that these authors
were actually measuring the two-way
speed of light
but i'm imagining you might have some
ideas for how to measure the one-way
speed of light so
let's go through some of them i mean
can't we just use a high-speed camera
that shoots at a trillion frames a
second so we can
actually see light passing through an
object the problem is you're not
only seeing the light pass through the
object you're also seeing it bounce back
to the camera
measuring the two-way speed not one way
here you go get a spool of fiber optic
cable
you know i don't know like 186 000 miles
and then and you could shine the light
here and you have the other end of the
fiber here and you could
shine here and then wait and see the
delay see if it's one second later over
here
the thing is like that fiber's going
around and around and around so
it could be that when the light goes
this way over the top of the
loop it goes slower and then when it
goes on the bottom it goes faster
it all averages out in the fiber and
you're you're essentially getting lots
of round trips in that fiber
so you're never getting a one way what
if you center a synchronizing device
between your two clocks
and send out simultaneous pulses well
if the speed of light is the same in
both directions this perfectly
synchronizes your clocks
but if the speed of light is different
in each direction
one of the clocks will be ahead of the
other and it will be ahead by
just the right amount so that when you
measure the speed of light
you will find the value to be c even
though
that was not the speed the light was
traveling this is the same reason
gps synchronized clocks won't work the
whole
gps system is based on the assumption
that the speed of light is the same in
all directions
if the speed of light is different in
different directions the light pulses
from satellites
will travel at different speeds so the
clocks won't be properly synced
by that i mean they will always measure
c for the one-way speed of light
whether it is or isn't
how about starting with synchronized
clocks in the middle
and moving them apart with equal and
opposite speeds
that way the time dilation for each
clock will be the same and they'll still
be synchronized
when they reach the end points but again
this only works if the speed of light in
each direction is the same
if the speed of light depends on
direction then so does
time dilation you might think you could
move the clocks
really really slowly so that time
dilation is negligible
but if the speed of light is different
in different directions
you can't just use the standard formula
to calculate what that time dilation
would be i mean it could be a lot worse
than you think
so the reality is we're stuck we need
synchronized clocks to measure the
one-way speed of light
but we need to know the one-way speed of
light in order to synchronize our clocks
now this might sound like just an
academic concern so i want to go through
an example to illustrate just how
differently the universe works
if the speed of light is not the same in
all directions
let's say on mars mark is trying to
synchronize his clock with the earth
at noon mission control sends out a
message that says
this signal was sent at exactly 12
o'clock when mark receives this message
he uses the einstein synchronization
convention to set his clock
he knows the round-trip time delay is 20
minutes so he assumes the signal must
have taken 10 minutes to reach him
he programs his clock to 12 10 pm and
sends a return message
this reply sent to 12 10.
the message is received on earth at 12
20 pm so both parties know the
synchronization was successful
when the clock reads 12 20 on earth it
simultaneously reads
1220 on mars
[Music]
but now consider what happens if the
speed of light is not the same in both
directions
let's say it is c over 2 from earth to
mars
and then instantaneous from mars back to
earth
no one knows this of course so they
continue to use the einstein convention
the message is sent from earth but now
it takes a full
20 minutes to reach mars but mark
doesn't know this
and as before he assumes the signal took
10 minutes to reach him so he sets his
clock to 12 10 pm
even though on earth it is now 12 20.
mark then sends
this reply sent to 12 10 pm which is
instantaneously received on earth
at 12 20 earth time
the experience for the two communicators
is the same
the same messages were received with the
same local time delays
but their clocks are out of sync by 10
minutes
what they think is the same moment for
the other observer
actually isn't and there is no way they
can ever recognize or
correct this error imagine if someone on
earth immediately responded
how long did this message take to reach
you it's now 12
20. well the message would take 20
minutes to reach mars
but due to the clocks being out of sync
it would arrive at 12 30 mars time
so mark would reply 10 minutes a message
that would
instantaneously reach the earth at 12 40
earth time
the space-time diagram shows how there
is flexibility in what you consider to
be the same moment
at two different locations and in how
you define the one-way speed of light
einstein chose the convention where the
one-way speed of light is always the
same
but from an experimental perspective any
other convention
is just as valid up to and including one
where the speed of light is c over two
one way
and instantaneous the other way
and in that case it's interesting to
think about what each observer is seeing
when they look
at the other mark would be seeing the
earth as it was
20 minutes ago but earth is seeing mars
in real time exactly as it is
right now and this effect wouldn't stop
at mars
look beyond it and you could see stars
hundreds of light years away
not as they looked centuries ago but
exactly
as they are right this instant
one of the things is you only know about
that light
when it reaches you and you don't know
anything about what journey it took to
get to you you just
see it and it's there so like it's
instantaneous
so an instantaneous interpretation of
that light is just as good as one where
it takes c to reach us
this is breaking my brain yeah yeah i
mean it's it's kind of unknowable isn't
it
it is unknowable that's the whole point
of the video is to say
we've all agreed and this is based on
something einstein wrote in 1905 we've
all agreed to just say
it's c in every direction but the truth
is the physics works the same
whether it's c or the c over two and
instantaneous
or anything in between as long as the
round trip works out to be c
none of physics breaks and that's the
crazy thing
so if we can never measure the one-way
speed of light and if it makes
no difference to any of the laws of
physics
then what's the point in even talking
about it
well that is certainly one valid
perspective in a debate that has been
ongoing since
1905. you know some physicists appeal to
occam's razor
isn't it just simpler if light travels
at the same speed in all directions
most working physicists just accept the
convention and move on with their lives
but i think it's important to point out
that it is just a convention
not an empirically verified fact
[Music]
personally i find it fascinating that
this is something about the universe
that is hidden from us
sure the round trip speed of light is c
but does the one-way speed
even have a well-defined value and if it
doesn't
what does that mean for the concept of
simultaneity
when is right now on mars
does it even make sense to talk about
things happening at the same time
if they're separated by distance you
know maybe
this is an odd quirk of the universe and
there's no good reason for it
or maybe when physics takes the next
paradomatic leap our inability to
measure the one-way speed of light
will be the obvious clue to the way
general relativity quantum mechanics
space and time are all connected
and we'll wonder why we didn't see it
before
hey this video was sponsored by kiwico
they create
awesome projects and toys to get kids
making i use their crates with my son
and they are a lot of fun while also
being educational
now for viewers of this video they are
offering 50 off your first month of any
crate
just go to kiwico.com veritasium50
and i'll put that link down in the
description below now
i think this is a fantastic offer
because these crates are a great
resource for learning at home
which is something anyone with kids is
doing a lot of
at the moment plus all the supplies you
need come
right in the box which means you don't
need to run to the store
which is again ideal now my kids are
still young but kiwico
offers eight subscription lines for
different age groups and different
topics
i do the koala crates with my oldest who
is now four
but the kit i'm actually showing you
here is for older kids
i built an infinity mirror which is
perfect for talking about the round trip
speed of light
there's lots of round trips going on in
here now can i just tell you how useful
it is to have a box turn up at your door
once
a month that is packed with fun things
to make all the supplies you need and
hours of entertainment right there
plus my son and i are learning something
new together
every month and we're connecting it's
become a special thing that we do
together so kiwi co is a perfect option
for a holiday gift
my son actually got his subscription
last year at this time
and i just think what other option will
get kids thinking
and doing throughout the year so for me
that's the most
important part i want my kids to feel
like they can make and discover things
on their own and these crates give them
that confidence
so click the link below to learn more
and for 50
off the first month of any crate go to
kiwico.com
veritasium50 i want to thank kiwiko for
sponsoring this episode and i want to
thank you for watching